first our top story this our court
papers filed on two key Trump campaign
aides special counsel Robert Muller's
team says that Michael Cohen the
president's former personal lawyer is a
vital witness in their investigation now
the Justice Department says candidate
Trump directed Cohen to make illegal
payments to buy the silence of women
whose claims of extramarital affairs
threatened his presidential campaign mr.
Trump of course has denied having an
affair and prosecutors say that former
Trump campaign chairman Paul mana Ford
broke his plea deal by lying to
investigators court papers claim that
mana Ford lied about his contacts with
an aide who allegedly had ties to
Russian intelligence
I'm here with insight on these and other
developments in Washington is Washington
Post national correspondent Phillip bump
Phillip good morning sir let's start
with it with the Cohen revealing 'he's
basically yesterday in that filing what
what do what are we learn now hear from
that so we learned a couple of new
details not a whole lot not an expansive
amount of information we learned for
example that Cohen apparently met with
another Russian national over the course
of the campaign 2015-2016 someone who
had some involvement in the Trump Tower
Moscow deal there already been rumblings
about that we learned primarily though
that the government has implicated
Donald Trump directly in those two
charges that Cohen pled guilty to last
August he plan to guilty due to campaign
finance related charges at the time
Cohen said that he'd been directed to
take those actions by President Trump in
this court document the government
attorneys US Attorney's themselves say
that Donald Trump is implicated is this
Cohen's word against against
theoretically against the president is
to some extent however the document also
articulates the Cohen provided them with
recordings in which both he spoke with
Trump about the deals and Cohen later
all said that the deals were made in
order to influence the election and
that's the thing that really violates
campaign finance laws according to Max
when I spoke with yesterday and that's
particularly problematic what's the
biggest thing that we learned in
relation to Paul man afford at this
point so Paul Manafort was even less
informative from the sense that there
were a lot of things that were
redecorating Paul Manafort had this
relationship with a guy named
Constantine Coulomb Nick who worked for
him when he was doing work in Ukraine
Kaleem Nick apparently has some
theoretical ties to Russian intelligence
there's a lot of redacted stuff about
Kalume Nick in there which you don't
really know a whole lot about the main
thing is that the prosecution was
outlining that mana fort had lied to
them on a number
of occasions trying to make the case for
ways in which you've been deceptive that
was the main thing we learned more
details about those deceptions do you
think the information in these documents
might change the focus for Democrats
take it who take control of Congress in
January
it probably won't necessarily documents
himself probably won't shift with the
direction the Democrats are planning on
heading the Democrats have this choice
they have to decide if they're going to
try and legislate with the Republicans
in the Senate and figure out you know
what they're going to do there or if
they're going to instead put more of
their emphasis on Donald Trump in these
investigations which you know the
Republican majority in house didn't
spend a lot of time on over the course
of the past two years I don't think
these documents change that but I think
it certainly is the case that as more
comes out with a rush investigation the
Democrats will be champing more at the
bit not to dive into them what about
pole metaphor what are the papers show
on that well I mean I think the the
Manta four papers the big question is
where this is going right so we got some
new hints that Moeller for example had
been looking more at this figure calling
Nick we knew was sort of in the
background he's already been indicted on
potential obstruction of justice charges
but you know we'd still looked the
mobile investigation is this giant black
box that all of us are trying to sort of
crack open unfortunately these were just
little slivers of light without you
besides the investigation it feels like
The Long Goodbye when it comes to white
house she's a chief of staff John and
Kelly what do we know right now so what
we know right now is there have been
rumors for some time that John Kelly has
been on his way out at one point even
John Kelly and president Trump step four
and said no he's gonna be here through
2020 to try and quell that but look it's
a tough job trying to constrain Donald
Trump in particular that's John Kelly's
jobs trying to keep the white house in
order and Donald Trump makes that very
difficult so it's been rumored for some
time now the rumblings are getting
louder and I guess we'll just sort have
to see we should mention that filip bump
came with an entourage known as Thomas
bump but we also call him baby bump here
[Laughter]
waiting for you and it's great to see
you thanks so much for being with us